dignitary's ladies gentlemen
twice in two days reminds me of the
ministry of interior position that youth
Azar's is also served mr. Rehman Malik
who recently got a PhD from Karachi
University my alma mater
I'm not laughing and government at the
moment but being here twice perhaps
makes me twice as eligible to be also
given one life um I don't know what to
say because one is known all the bad
things about episodes but starting off
with license from all of you couple of
snippets from history which I rather
revel in one as you know mr. Jinnah was
very strongly supported by my ancestors
lived in a house for many piece of time
as a charity by the way but coming back
to Jinnah we spoke about 1952 in north
or something I know about ironically
Jenner never spoke or do in his life
didn't know murder although all his
speeches were in English and all his
conduct was in English so I wonder my
order was that important to that stage
and certainly we for one felt in our
house that it wasn't necessary to be
imposed on Bengal as of course it was
not a part of their tradition but having
said that I just thought I'd share that
with you and I would like to say
something which most probably is the
best way to introduce episode s which is
I believe every country must have a
balance in that balance where
third-world countries have lost their
armies they have lost practically the
sovereignty of their nations as well two
recent examples perhaps would be good
examples
the one is enough and one is of
understand what I'm saying is we must
learn that everywhere even the night a
Democrat democracies of the world have
mighty armies behind them and those
armies have a role to play my cab yet to
water said earlier and I would have
liked to have participated but I don't
think I was allowed to and that is that
we have had plenty of opportunities in
Bangladesh and in Pakistan it more so in
fact that it's the civilians conduct
themselves the way they ought to and
believe me there are many examples
internationally and otherwise and though
I'm not saying by any stretch of
imagination that what the anglo-saxon
left us was in any way completely free
from shall we say bias it wasn't there
were many instances where decisions that
were taken even in this so much coveted
judiciary well not the same as they were
in their own country so having said that
what I feel we have to say is that if we
are to see the back of the military is
one we have to understand that we have
to bring up the standards of democracy
to such a level that the people support
it so completely in overhung
overwhelmingly that they do not say time
and again my god this country is down
the tubes we've got to do something love
them calm and I believe that off late we
have the same opportunities we again did
not there has to be clean government's
we cannot have elites being created
through the backdoor and patronage and
the poor suffering incessantly we must
understand that our own colonial
leftovers have not even been shaved let
alone discarded and those in fact lead
towards stronger militarized
in action and it's not something judge
just has to do democracy there has to be
some moral behavior you can't just
ignore morality in this there has to be
look at the of honnest on when the first
troops came in from the United States
they laid out a program 20% military 20%
infrastructure I'm sorry
20% building up of bureaucratic
infrastructure and institutional answer
from infrastructure 60% was meant to be
building up the the wealth of the nation
or enabling trade and as such any such
thing that would promote everyone to
have a wallet in their trousers or bags
or whatever and of course the 20%
military has gone up to 350 billion
dollars accumulated over years the rest
is not quite but do you realize we have
things coming in in fits in start very
much like the kerry-lugar-berman
was meant to create a certain
infrastructure educational specifically
in the tribal areas to discourage the
boundaries from being what they are and
instead we get Joe alright you need so
much money for a flood take it from the
carry Luger we have so much for this to
take it from the carry Luger we have so
much of that take it from I wonder what
carry Ruger and say and then the
disbursement is pathetic so the question
and that and the disbursement was meant
to be done by NGOs so let us not take
institutions towards a situation where
we feel they have all the answers being
non-governmental is just good enough I
was reading a book from this very
University about the professor since
Emma Richards and we talked about
economics and that of course in anything
he says that you cannot take these
aspects for granted and I come back to
that we have to understand there are
fail abilities there are shortcomings
and there are many pragmatics which do
not apply over time so harmony in
whichever way it's possible some sort of
equilibrium that can balance the various
factors
and that is where we come to Etta's ours
as in who seeks to restore balance first
met him at a gathering by Hirshman Singh
and kodi neeya under general Hawk in
1982-83 where they were talking to the
then burgeoning restoration of democracy
movement and he was sitting in the third
last row and I was in the last row and
he was making himself very voluble and
being heard in a very strident fashion
and everyone thought well that's the
brave young man
of course titles many many years ago he
has done much more since then when I was
speaker the synth assembly and the
assembly was prorogued by me the locks
were broken on the assembly and the
doors opened and a man installed in a
seat and I was removed by the people who
had been referred to the Election
Commission in question of their
qualifications as they had broken rules
of democracy and under that they had not
entitled or enabled to sit in the house
but they did that and my name plates
were drawn from the Speaker of the
assembly in all of Karachi with many
distinguished lawyers not one
volunteered to stand up and act on
behalf of the speaker and f''s ours did
agreed to appear and he travelled every
week for something like two years on a
matter of urgent public importance for
two years and when the Chief Minister
who himself was from the a former
judiciary and was a sitting justice and
should never have been enabled to become
chief minister because that was a role I
coveted and I had the votes but he was
imposed by a change of rules what we
have is the playing ground remains
the same the goal posts are moved many
many yards to the right or left so you
don't know which side of the field
you're playing on and when he was
ultimately removed of course everything
died and there was no decision that
would have helped history but ethicist
stood by and fought have always been
grateful to him but this is a good place
as any to say it publicly
I would also then like to refer to
various aspects of his career he was
with Benazir in the first spring he was
the minister in Syria and of course he
played his very substantial role then
and nothing that I didn't in fact I
remember of that but the more recent
role that he played and for which we as
a family awarded him my grandfather's on
the founders of Pakistan awarded him a
prize in his name for helping democracy
and I remember that as the movement of
the lawyers and the judiciary
where they got in deeper to play a role
as the Constitution of Pakistan says
it's a trichotomy and the judiciary
even today haven't really got the powers
as outlined in the Constitution for them
and the cause was taken up and he
battled bravely to substantial costs to
himself and substantial trouble for his
family his friends and everything that
he stood with about they sold it on the
photon and they came to a point where
things had to be changed and it was not
by any concession it was taken which
brings me to a point I'd like to relate
to you that when one of the greatest
Muslims of the Indians of
the UH Gahan prince alum was requested
by his friend servitude whose daughter
was marrying Jenna out of his community
the Zoroastrian community not to allow
his disciple to marry her Jenna said to
her I'm very sorry but I've gotta do
this and they became estranged about sir
Sultana and Jenna realized that both
were essential to each other so the
closest friend to both of them will set
up the LA haroon my grandfather and they
sort of said but you will play in
between the run stage Jenna asked him to
request her salon having the sonority as
being president of the League of Nations
to take the chair for the roundtable
conference and says well Ann said well
please tell him that chagum day should
be the one as he's the senior-most in
India and represents the largest
community the Hindu community and when
my grandfather George in our doesn't
seem likely well my grandfather
accompanied sir Jenna to that meeting in
the borrowers house when the Viceroy
walked in said five minutes peace
electro leader and I should be back and
as he left sir Sudan stood up and said
I've nominated Sri Gandhi as leader of
Hindu India which is the majority vast
majority now Gandhi was about to make
his acceptance speech but he didn't want
to be put into that narrow confine
so he started off and it's a very
effusive fashion that we're all equal
here and mr. Jinnah is as great a leader
of India as I am I'm sorry mr. Sultana
Gahan and on that moment sussel town
stood up and said as mr. Gandhi as
leader of majority India has reposed his
confidence in me I thank you and he went
and sat on the chair it was all
nonplussed all round but that was that
and what mayor leaving my grandfather
said to him but you said you weren't
going to do this he said sell of the law
power is never given it is taken so that
was the maxim which
I shall say brought the judiciary back
into its own in Pakistan and I think
that it's over simplifying it but then
perhaps that might be a little
explanation or the fact that nothing was
conceded it was taken and continues
today in that fashion despite the huge
balancing act which has to take place
necessarily but more than that I think
that the people that left examples RUF
us illustrating India was one family the
way as I've said yesterday how we could
have had differences a big manor houses
divided the cultures don't stray to
change the bloodlines don't change the
traditions don't change and everything
remains fairly much the fact that at one
stage with the darlings of the world and
World Bank quoted else is the best
example of an economic developing stage
in the 1960s the fact we're where we are
today
and India being very progressively
advanced today way beyond anyone I think
it basically with imagine many many many
ways of course there differences that's
the way it is for nature and society but
there is an overwhelming homogeneity and
which a lot of which can be contributed
by the British but also because it had
its own checks and balances which helped
each other be the way they are and I
believe that over time if our civilian
societies in Bangladesh and Pakistan can
lead by example if the leadership is not
as corrupt as anyone else that one can
point a finger at if the leadership
takes decisions if it moves in those
live within those limitations and
parameters which form a good stage I
think everything is possible and we can
learn to work with each other and if you
have people who lead by example I don't
know what anyone else would say but I
think those people do of course many
such people do get
nated violently which is unfortunate but
that many survive and do a lot of good
and I believe that that inherent good is
in all of us as it is in SRS and whose a
very very emphatic voice as well and
he's going to read some of his poetry to
you today how that is going to be
translated I think Janicki better to a
good actor I don't know what's going to
happen but he will
I think translated perhaps himself and
besides all that I think the important
thing to mention is that he's been a
strong pillar of society in the Hall and
in Pakistan he has strong commitments I
believe he has a strong model streak
which I would like to mention in absence
of his beloved wife Bush who's not here
has a lot to do with it and his young
son Ali who was here a little while
earlier and may know easier yes and I
think that being shall we say ensconced
between the two there's very little
margin beyond the point but nevertheless
not only him very well brought up family
who all have commitments and work
towards social goal of social
improvements in Pakistan his vital just
with the cricket team in in the West
Indies if I'm not wrong so she's not
here today but diverse in character and
not the typical person who would be
speaking to you today here from Pakistan
up in Pakistan has its diversity it has
its strong moments it has its weak
moments we may be on the weaker side of
things but let me tell you that two
years ago India and Pakistan at the UN
work together on so many issues and
worked so hard that we've actually
wagged the tail and I think a lot of
things are today happening which started
off and are initiated here in terms of
cooperation where the two ambassadors
said all right let's first say what are
the major
and it ironed out to one or maybe two
and that's where we started from we've
gone a long way since the usual fanfare
of the duels between the two were
further ridiculed by us last year when I
stood up and proposed the Indian
ambassador of the Security Council and
then we wrote it openly showing our boat
saying we want this to be absolute and
today despite for the press says in
India we still have that close
relationship and with us congesting will
most probably get their support also at
the right moment and all this I believe
all goes well for the future of a
subcontinent which is not that difficult
for all of us to get together and be one
there is a strong strain of history and
that keeps us very much together we
squabble like any progeny of siblings
that is not the rule that is what makes
it diverse enjoyable and keeps all of
you interested in our part of the world
thank you David
excellency ik was there the ladies and
gentlemen it's a privilege to have been
invited to this conference and it is an
additional privilege to have been
introduced as a speaker by none other
than the Pakistani ambassador to the
United Nations and a gentleman of great
standing and of a vision a South Asian
vision I am also grateful to the
organizers of this conference for having
invited me to participate in it and
particularly to give him for giving me
the rare honor of being the closing
plenary speaker I'm myself no scholar on
the subjects that we have discussed over
the last two days I almost feel like the
plumber with a hammer or a carpenter
with a saw barging into the onto the
stage where the Philharmonic Orchestra
is being played because such was the
precision and such was the ingenuity of
expression that I heard yesterday in
particular and to some extent today that
I felt at times quite out at sea
personally myself but the terminology
was fined tuned
undoubtedly to the subjects being
discussed like feminism secularism other
such subjects and the intensity of the
debate on them
and the as I said terminology that was
to which I was a stranger to some extent
for instance if I may say so to Deepti
confabulate the post structural
performativity
from permittivity of the in cursive
rearrangement of desire in recognition
if I miss if I may complete this 2d
confabulate the post structural perform
it perform IVA T of the uncor Civ
rearrangement of desire in recognition
of the different textual nuances of the
located and the diasporic populations as
I understood this it meant that
secularism could mean different things
the diasporic view the local view and
the and secularism itself the uncor
severy a general desire and to put it
simply even there secularism and even
more simply it really means and boils
down to the right of different choices
but you know I heard some great
arguments and great concepts I've
learned a lot I'm much the Richer
although I would suggest that
terminology is not necessarily the
reality it's very necessary I am
reminded of debate in the National
Assembly which
which I was arguing as I've argued
elsewhere in one of my books that
Pakistan was created not as an as an
Islamic state but as a Muslim state so I
was arguing this in the National
Assembly in a debate on the women's
marathon and whether women had the right
father to run the marathon which had
which they had tried to do including my
wife and they'd been beaten up by some
mullahs of Shah Baba milli and we had
moved the adjournment motion on that I
was one of the signatories and I was
trying to explain that what muhammad ali
jinnah barrister Gina wanted to create
was a Muslim state and not an Islamic
state a Muslim state in the sense that
France might be characterized or Britain
might be characterized
despite their plurality now as Christian
States Italy a Christian state not
necessarily that the state is Christian
but there could be a different
definition of Pakistan as a Muslim state
Saudi Arabia is a Muslim state but while
Saudi Arabia is also an Islamic state
where Sharia rules Pakistan I was trying
to assert was a Muslim state when the
law minister got up interrupted me and
my speech on a point of order and he
said mr. speaker sir take a look at the
constitution it is called the
Constitution is called the constitution
of the Islamic Republic of Pakistan it
is the Islamic Republic of Pakistan what
I've been trying to argue that in
content and substance it was still the
Muslim state although it was called an
Islamic Republic now those who will
understand who do and even bangla will
Rob
we understand it first when I got up I
finally got the chance to respond I said
mr. speaker the Honorable worthy law
Minister is called share of gun he is
called share of gun he can kill a little
lion he is killed a lion is the killer
of a lion but he would be he would run
away from a mouse he is called his name
is shade of gun so what's in a name what
is in terminology after all what I think
the ideas that were expressed were were
brilliant were indeed enlightening and
on top of it Sahra Hussein came to wind
up last night session and she set a very
high bar for me
this young girl from Bangladesh and she
set it a set a very high bar for not
only for me but I think from the
uncoerced of etc etc etc she came
through to us through the in the
simplest of language and I thought that
speech was mesmerizing and she did not
get into complicated terminology but
then she's her father's daughter a
father dr. cominis and she was very
modest
Sahra when she mentioned so many cases
that her father has been pursuing in
bangladesh force at the advancement of
civil society for human rights and when
she said she spoke as the lawyer my lord
this that and the other and she did
mention just once the lordship said mr.
husai what mr. Hussein and that mr.
Hussein was mr. combat
dr. Guevara said Bangladesh is former
foreign minister and a great campaigner
and a great inspiration for South Asians
so much was said and I will be delayed
reading on it somewhat in my paper so
much was said on the 1971 conflict it's
been actually a major theme because it
was Bangladesh Pakistan without as
somebody said mentioning India Dena and
John Key had kept an awkward kept India
out of it which is which is good enough
in so many ways but Pakistan and
Bangladesh were actually born as twins
tied at the hip and the surgery to
divide them necessarily was was had to
be painful I am NOT defending any action
you will see in my paper I have a very
different view on that but I think we
have to move forward and rather than
necessarily after 40 years thinking of
war crimes you already started
Bangladesh had already started seven
people are being tried I don't know
whether it will purge the ghosts of the
terror the night of terror unleashed on
the East Pakistanis in March 26th of
March 1971 whether they it will purge
the ghosts of that purged the
apparitions the memories by such trials
perhaps a greater a better model to
follow might be although it's for you to
decide on that might be the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission of the South
African pattern because the brutality
that the blacks in Africa had faced has
no parallel perhaps in history after
the brutality of the Egyptian pharaohs
on their on their populace and subjects
my paper itself is strictly on the topic
damar beyond security Democratic contest
ations in Pakistan I have I was
persuaded to some extent by Janaki and
Akbar to revise the paper that I had
submitted some seven days ago they were
surprised that a plenary speaker who I'm
grateful to them for their appreciation
would submit a paper in writing so early
but they got after me and they said you
haven't met emphasized too much the
lawyers movement and we want to hear
about the lawyer's movement I revised it
a bit to add a little more to the on the
lawyer's movement but I was a little you
might say inhibited in that because I
thought it would be so much self at you
lately that I would should avoid it or
underplay it but they they have thought
that the audience and the gathering here
is this very very distinguished
gathering which really overalls me also
quite frankly would like to hear more
about the lawyers movement also so I
have I will expand expound on that to
some extent finally before I go to my
paper
I think it's propitious that and very
expedient that I have been kept as the
last speaker I don't know whether those
who arranged the conference and sat down
and worked on it and denied Janicki and
Albert were conscious of the fact that
four five four three years I've been the
leader of the Opposition in the Senate
of Pakistan
now that implies that all my speeches
and up with me leading a walkout so but
this one they've played very safe
they've played safe the I may mention
one thing just in passing because I may
forget to the it otherwise I'd be a
little disappointed with a question
which said when is box I'm going to
become a good state there is this is all
relative and I feel hurt by it
the Pakistanis are a group as we will
see in I will try to I will try and
endeavor to establish in my submissions
here are a good race they are in the
theater war the war has been thrust upon
us the combatant is not us the combatant
is the other the combatant of course
denies women their rights blows up
schools schools particularly of girls
schools boys schools blows up
barbershops blows up television shops
his against woman is against education
is against entertainment but that is not
us and please do not characterize us as
that I felt slightly hurt with that very
question itself but leaving it behind
and I said my the subject of my paper is
strictly because there have been papers
that have been gone beyond or outside
the purview but mine is strictly and
beyond security Democratic contest
stations in
guess not and particularly with the
Bangladesh and bangle in action and at
the outside I might say that the main
contestants and the contest stations
have been between democracy their land
owning feudal the military the civil
bureaucracy of a weak bourgeoisie the
mullah the fundamentalist and the
judiciary and what has been the
interplay and the evolution of these
factors and these contestants and these
protagonists is what I will be speaking
about foreclosure introduced by the
company was not a concept known to the
Indian funerals they had always been in
debt but had never lost their lands for
on that count the company by contrast
was a commercial enterprise as the
company expanded its commercial
operations and clamped the vise-like
military grip the feudal first went into
debt and particularly in Bengal and then
lost their lands land now came to be
cultivated through riches rain tears as
the British set up trading posts in
Bengal its traders merchants and
bookkeepers work for half a century at
least the exclusive intermediaries of
the British trade in India to the feudal
Hindu or Muslim the position of an
account keeper or moonshee was abhorrent
even when he had lost his entire land
holding it was the merchant it that
position was for the merchant princely
Bengal would fight bravely but fall at
Plassey in 1757 and something that my
bangla friends might know
he will cerrado dollar was betrayed by
his muslim general mere Jaffa and he was
mourned by his friend the van Ram
Narayan a Hindu whose poi whose whose
verse has become one of the most
important most quoted verses of the u2
language Allah talked about before
aho Matua Calgary
davana Marga Akiko Viren o Kekaha the
partnership between the Indian merchants
and the British forged early in the 18th
century was to last well into the 19th
in fact it lifes lasted precisely up to
the conquest of the by the British of
Indus which is Pakistan and it helped
the gradual growth of the bourgeoisie in
India the conquest then the conquest of
the Indus in 1843 and Sindh in 1843 and
Punjab in 18-49 almost a hundred years
after Plassey in 1757 opened up new
prospects for the colonial power vast
tracts of potentially arable land were
at its feet as he began to map the jaw
and chart these endless deserts and
plains the British officer in the end a
rich and prolific granary for the Empire
he saw new class of landlords as the key
player in the Indus system after the
suppression of the uprising in 1857 it
was thus expedient for the British to
switch partners the merchant bourgeoisie
had paved the way and paid for the
armies to win the Empire now the feudal
was needed to bring in the harvest in
Indus in fact the British themselves
first installed the feudal 's and then
began to empower and to use them this
class would
the foremost impediment in the way of
democracy in Pakistan
thus the surplus produce of the native
health peasant had to be farmed out of
this colony the feudal would extract the
produce and surrender it to the district
collector for the imperial power this
new arrangement was for to the benefit
of all parties to the compact the
peasant had they had his piece the
feudal his prestige while the imperial
bureaucratic network expropriated the
produce of Indus and India 100 years
after plus he it was now the turn of the
Indian bourgeoisie to be left out in the
cold the colonial state helped entrench
the Indus feudal the Punjab land
alienation act was promulgated in
nineteen nineteen hundred it
disqualified non agrarian tribes from
acquiring the holdings of agricultural
lands unlike the rent years in London in
Bengal a hundred years ago this was in
sharp contrast to what the company had
done in Bengal it had in the in Bengal
it had allowed non land owning creditors
to uproot the indebted landowner in
Indus that is Pakistan the colonial
government protected the landowner from
dispossession in Bengal land had become
a market commodity adding to the
strength and resources of the
bourgeoisie the Punjab land alienation
act impeded this development while
preemption laws facilitated the landed
gentry with large holdings to acquire
more and more adjoining pieces soon they
owned vast tracts and became absently
few rules
political power followed economic power
by the time of the First World War
therefore these agro feudal areas became
steadfast bastions of the raj this
switching of allies was crucially
significant to the future of the
subcontinent as India profited by the
rod as
Indus Ansari in disputed by the Raj the
trade and business classes of India
began to compete with and resent
Imperial manufacturers they now sought
to organize themselves economically and
politically they required both a trade
organization to advance their
substantial economic interests as well
as a political party to win for them the
necessary political privileges and
economic space it is therefore no mere
coincidence that the Indian Chamber of
Commerce and the Indian National
Congress were established in the same
year 1885 this awakening of the business
classes sought to rid all Indian
domestic markets of foreign manufactures
meantime the importance of Indus was
highlighted for another reason - in the
uprising of 1857 Indus had played a
critical role for the colonial power
it was hence forced to become the
indispensable and become indispensable
to the defense of the Empire as
bourgeois interest began to convulse
India Indus remained calm profiting by a
larger agricultural produce than it had
ever witnessed in history irrigation
canals had increased arable land there
was enough water for all crops the
Punjab peasant was being inducted into
the Imperial Army that would be the
second contestant against democracy the
army the First World War impelled the
Imperial Government to increment
increment increment Lee incrementally
erased the size of the army it was
largely raised in Indus young in
dispersants and listed in the Army in
great numbers this also became a crucial
turning point for in this city the war
took the in dispersant soldier to many
parts of the world he was exposed to
ideas and technological advances that
had never
envisioned in his cloistered will
village by the time he returned to the
his Bullock Bullock cart plow and
indebtedness his perspective had been
enlarged a regular pension gave him some
social security and status he had many
tales to tell in a time and landlocked
social capsule his village this much
traveled cosmopolitan rose to a new
social height and acquired significant
respect and influence in society
contemporary folk songs reflected his
new status vasana haji then our famiiy
butanol la Temari i will live with the
soldier even if he kicks me with his
boots on thus even as the bourgeoisie
moved up the social ladder in india the
soldier having fought for alien masters
gained an aura and a mystique in the
indus the demarcation between democracy
and Praetorian ism was becoming vivid
the third contestant to democracy was
also involving under the raj as the
canal and rail network expanded the
civil bureaucracy exercise control over
the process of land settlement land
records distribution of water in the
canal irrigated areas and the
expropriation called procurement and
transport of the surplus produce this
gave it great leverage over the
landowner
and the peasant it consolidated the
bureaucracy in a preeminent position and
the Indus claw and the Indus class that
could have aspired for democracy the
bourgeoisie was given no chance despite
it being a sugar and cotton producing
area Pakistan or Indus had only one
sugar mill and one textile mill at the
time of partition India in 1947
it had become a cotton growing appendage
to the textile mills of Lancashire the
Indus border
therefore remaining next to non-existent
it remained under the shadow and
political influence of the feudal gentry
and of the Imperial bureaucracy yet
Jena used this week indisputable uz and
inspired the student and in the inspired
students to bring down the Indus feudal
Goliath he reached out to the broad
masses over the shoulders of the
bureaucrat and the feudal the feudal
dominated synth assembly took the lead
by adopting a resolution endorsing the
Muslim League pursuit for Pakistan the
Punjab ela landowners were soon to fall
then second area the Punjab premier and
his landlord dominated punjab national
unionist party embrace Jana's Muslim
League a more telling story is that of
surveys Araya Teavana
he succeeded Sikandar Hayat as the prime
minister of Punjab
Havana's great ancestor had aided the
British in the 1857 uprising as had high
odds he had himself campaigned
vigorously to recruit soldiers from the
Punjab during the World War but Gina's
garters and choose the broad masses into
a vigorous campaign against the slogan
his Rivas arith todo dissolved the
government of his erhi Teavana many a
feudal young turk Mumtaz da Dada
Shaka taught and if the cardamom dog
came under pressure and joined the
Muslim League as hayaat had done earlier
Tawana also capitulated and made up with
Gina League crowds at once began to
shout Dada
uber is fazer Amara by the news has just
come in that Heiser is our brother even
though the League victory 1946 was
crucially the gift of feudal opportunism
there was one very positive aspect of it
it routed the
Islamic fundamentalist the
fundamentalist by-and-large held back
from the Pakistan movement
their position was that Islam being a
universal religion could not be
territorially defined Islam could not be
confined to physical and geographical
determined borders Jinnah exploded the
argument at partition partition
therefore Pakistan had a strong feudal
class a powerful army and entrenched
civil service and an insignificant
beauty of bourgeoisie Pakistan inherited
all that baggage from the Raj that was
likely to impede its progress towards
democracy fares of course spend the
following despondent thought from his
prison cell
later Yadav Davao Jalla yob Ghazi does a
hell came to Darth a disco give us a
hair tonic in this dark dark died on
this night infested dawn surely this was
not the dawn we had hoped for
under the Raj bureaucracy and ER the
DAAD the bureaucracy had enjoyed
remarkable autonomy and independence
they had indeed been free to report
directly to governor's disregarding the
wishes if any of the native ministers
after partition this was formalized by a
clever bureaucrat during China's own
lifetime
Chaudhary Mohammad Ali a senior of
official persuaded Jana to create the
office of secretary general to the
Secretary General to the Government of
Pakistan Ali himself became the first
incumbent the cabinet then gave to the
Secretary General of supervisory
authority over every ministry employing
his authority Mohammed Ali set up a
planning committee of the cabinet of
which of which secretaries of all
ministries were members he presided over
head the committee was soon use up all
the functions of the cabinet thus bypass
divested of decision-making politicians
big
feeble and fickle in the three years
that the office of Secretary General
existed it consolidated the bureaucratic
grip on the political structure of
Pakistan alongside the civil bureaucracy
the army also displayed an urge to
continue to remain autonomous of
political authority the problem had
began early the first two commanders in
chief were both British generals Frank
Messer V and Douglas Gracie
besides reporting to the government of
Pakistan always turned for guidance to
their superior Field Marshal Sir Claude
Auchinleck in Delhi this naturally
created a duality of control instances
are quoted in which commanders are said
to have disregarded the defense ministry
ministry is even Gina's instructions and
I would recommend children as is booked
on this this be Iran the first Pakistani
since commander-in-chief general Ayub
Khan was appointed to that office in
January 1951 a little over a year later
the anti Amethi riots broke out in
Punjab there was large-scale rioting and
looting in the hall the city I was
handed over to the army it immediately
restored law and order
by contrast politicians were in a
tailspin Jana's death in September 1948
had left a gaping void then in 1953
Prime Minister Liaquat Ali Khan was
assassinated in Rawalpindi as the
politicians entered a game of musical
chairs generally you can took a seat in
the cabinet as a defense minister this
development has had an indelible
seemingly irreversible effect on the
history of Pakistan the long-term impact
of this his one-year tenure was immense
until they here we have until he was
made the defense minister in October
1954 a you've had as C&C been reporting
to the
French Minister as defense minister
himself he began reporting to himself a
tradition was established that the army
chief would virtually be his own boss
appointments transfers and promotions in
military became the sole prerogative of
the army chief couple couple this with
the parliamentary tradition of passing
the entire defense budget has framed by
the military without a debate not even a
word and you have a military state
within a state the dissolution of the
assembly in 1954 had enabled the
bureaucratic Governor General with the
help from the judiciary to obtain a
pliant indirectly elected parliament he
turned to Constitution making this was
not a simple task
the Urdu and Punjabi speaking elite of
West Pakistan had always feared East
Buxton's majority a natural corollary to
its larger population therefore by an
administrative order all the provinces
of West Pakistan and the several
autonomous states were merged into one
administrative and political entity the
one unit with the merger a federation of
only two units was created East Pakistan
and West Pakistan
therefore thereafter an artificial
parity of representation between East
Pakistan and West Pakistan was adopted
despite the inequality of population the
1956 Constitution was thus built on sand
administratively the one unit was an
easy trick politically it was a disaster
a procession of four prime ministers
Muhammad Ali shades Robert Dijon rigger
and Don followed ian Talbot has decided
put it graphically Prime Minister moved
through the revolving doors of the
office with increasing rapidity as power
slipped from karachi to the army
headquarters in Rawalpindi it does is at
right of the
raishin that while India in its first
decade had one prime minister in several
army Chiefs Pakistan had several prime
ministers and one Pakistani army chief
stability in the one office and the
instability in the other naturally upset
the power denomination in to see
military leadership was smug and
confident but the army was alarm only
when in 1958 it was announced that a
general election with adult franchise
would be held in February 1959 a
genuinely elected and refreshed assembly
what would most likely have the will the
mandate and the authority to tame the
Wildcats opposed to democracy and to
strip them of their powers martial law
was promulgated on the 8th of October
1958 although generally you can't give a
new constitution in 1962 and introduced
many reforms the most perfect of the
military takeover in 1958 was that it
converted what was conceptually a
welfare state into a national security
state this conversion was logical the
only justification that had been claimed
ever for a long-term and comprehensive
military rule is a perceived and
perennial threat to the security of the
state without such a perception army
rule cannot be defended India now became
that threat the 1953 48 Indo Park
conflict and early in the park tension
on water resources and division of
assets had caused considerable
bitterness between the two neighbors yet
India had not been perceived as a threat
to the security of Pakistan Pakistan saw
it as an illegal occupant of the state
of Jammu and Kashmir but relations
between the two states remained far
better than they are now visas were easy
to come by
Indian films were box-office hits in
Pakistan mokuba
nergis Dilip Kumar and Raj Kapoor
adorned the massive billboards
cross-border matches in cricket
volleyball hockey Kabaddi football dude
substantial crowds in 1960 I used the
CNC president himself into the Indus
Water Treaty that divided the waters of
Pakistani rivers between India and
Pakistan Ayub as CNC had also guided
Pakistan into treaty arrangements with
the United States and obtain substantial
military hardware profiting from
America's communist phobia but to fully
justify its continued all-embracing rule
for a prolonged an indefinite period the
army had to fight wars it thought it
might win a challenge India in the Rann
of Kutch in 1964 and provoked the
full-scale war over Kashmir in 1965
India's hostility towards Pakistan was
now shown as providing a complete
justification for the otherwise
illegitimate military rule in Pakistan
when after a full decade in power a huge
grip began to loosen martial law was
again proclaimed and a US Constitution
have rotated in March 1969 there was a
popular uprising in East Pakistan which
they tried to crush by brutal military
means the civil war ended with the
intervention of the Indian Army and the
defeat and surrender of Pakistan's
Eastern Command in December 16 1971 East
Pakistan became Bangladesh Fairs again
loved and lamented the bloody military
regime military operation god mother
mae-eye ghee they'd have sub Zakir Baja
hoon gets a bid to leg a kidney births
are talked about when will we see the
spring of shining leaves and foliage
how many monsoons will take - will it
take to wash the stains of blood in West
Pakistan the defeated military
commanders no longer able to hold on to
power invited Zulfikar Ali Bhutto to
form a government Bhutto chose not to
take any advantage of that opportunity
to reduce Praetorian ISM he kept the
generals immune from blame or trial
rehabilitating the morale of the
Pakistan army but would Bhutto be
rewarded for this Bhutto zone ultimate
fail his ouster and arrest by his own
appointed army chief his execution on
the verdict of a superior dude of the
superior judiciary on oath of allegiance
to the will of the his military
detractor highlights another compound
that having been formalized early had by
now solidified the compact between the
military and the judiciary both abhorred
democracy until now the Pakistan
judiciary had been consistent and
constant in one respect it has
legitimized all military interventions
since the ruling elite was reversed to
holding general elections
it sought legitimacy by other means
unhappily the judiciary seemed all too
willing always to provide it to validate
the dissolution of 1958 however the
court leaned upon the doctrine of
necessity as Salus populi supreme elects
until now this diss continues to subvert
democratic structures and to provide
unceasing justification to Praetorian
interventions its most famous
application was in 1958 in the words of
Chief Justice monied if the attempt to
break the Constitution fails those who
sponsor or organize rate are judged by
the existing Constitution as guilty of
the crime of treason but a victorious
revolution or a successful coup d'etat
is an internationally recognized legal
method of changing a constitution when
military takeover were made by Zia and
General Musharraf in 77 and 1999
unabashedly the court applied Moniz
Austin Ian's criterion again and again
but as the judiciary stamped its
approval on military interventions and
political elements also displayed no
great verb and energy democracy cannot
flourish without political parties
political parties haven't have in
general failed Pakistan the All India
Muslim League had led the Pakistan
movement that had led the Pakistan
movement was not even a party in the
real sense it was a movement and Jana
kept a tight control on it
nominating office bearers and members to
every committee and parliamentary born
and then Jana had died in September 1948
that left the Muslim League in a lurch
and totally at sea since then Pakistan
has had political parties of three types
parties with the nationwide constituency
regional parties and religious parties
however all parties have shown certain
command common attributes the leader
exercises greatest influence and control
on the policy and objectives of the
party he is above criticism from within
his own party even where he makes
serious mistakes the leader nominates
central and provincial office bearers
and retains the authority to remove them
Pakistani political parties have also
been afflicted with split ISM and
factionalism I discussed individual
parties which I'm leaving out but even
the parties that did have a nationwide
constituency shared some other inherent
flaws with the larger ones that hindered
progress towards democracy they opposed
land reforms without meaningful land
reforms Pakistan remained locked in a
virtual political and economic paralysis
even capital formation was impeded
slowing down the emergence of the
business and industrial elite on a large
or a large middle class however the
emergence of an industrial elite and
rich bourgeoisie was unfortunately also
entirely state-sponsored and the gift of
the bureaucratic elite the Pakistani
bourgeoisie barring the very
whew thus never sought the dismantling
of the colonial state and its
replacement by a democratic structure
the entire process of industrialization
and Claire and credit was regulated by
the system of licenses and permits this
ensured at once the bureaucrats control
as well as the arbitrariness of patron
client relationship
neither self generated financial
resources nor technical professionalism
were required to set up industry all
that was necessary were good connections
with a high functionary of state with
the license came credit as well as the
facility to acquire land at less than
one-fifth of its market value with the
licenses would also come the opportunity
to obtain foreign exchange from the
state bank much of the sanctioned
foreign exchange was stashed away in
foreign accounts by overvaluing imported
machinery and other accounts and and
components since the accumulation of
capital and wealth was only possible
under state patronage and had not been
earned by sweat or toil or family
savings the industrial elite were
reduced to being minions of the
bureaucratic state credit was doled out
collaterals were overvalued default was
rampant foreclosure was unheard of
rescheduling and write-offs became the
rule tax evasion was widespread Giants
of Pakistani industry at their four feet
of clay they had never supported
democratic movements as the crony
capitalists flourish the state became
impoverished and the differences and in
incomes and lifestyles became stark
extremes of prosperity and poverty
provided ground for another opponent of
democracy to step on to the stage Jeana
had ever had abhorred theocracy he had
spoken often and unambiguously about the
state and religion being separate but
the fundament
had their feet weekly in 1953 in the
anti MD arrived the anti em the movement
did not enlarge the narrow word Bank of
the fundamentalist it did however
bequeathed to the orthodoxy some clout
in the politics of the country at a time
when Pakistan was joining us sponsored
military PACs against communism the
central treaty organization and Osito
the u.s. then was itself in the throes
of McCarthyism the mullahs supported the
Pakistani state in its own witch hunt
for a witch hunt for intellectual
writers free thinkers besides socialists
and communists writers like Goro Toulon
Heather is much of science ja zal were
driven away to India
others like Siddhartha sonmanto star yet
others like Falmouth fans Habib jolly
sip Thea Sun and major Mamata sock spent
long years in jail
the campaign made Pakistan into what I
shall our goals and intellectual
intellectual wasteland and jolibois
wanted kaha cattle but after a focus
area without their top NASA for her fast
lap he such of their faces change but
not the assassins journey is is blighted
as we advance but cover no distance but
the fundamentalist would never be would
never could never yet dream of coming
into power they were routed in every
election the liberal minded bureaucrat
and the military officer despised them
the feudal looked down upon them there
they came with General Zia they sat in
his cabinet as he hanged the deposed
Prime Minister the Afghan resistance to
Soviet occupation was lubricated by US
dollars and weapon system Pakistani
fundamentalist parties fed the ranks of
the Mujahideen these parties have a
higher however being conceited enormous
space by the generals the politicians
and the media the entire environment of
the country is changed politics in the
name of drama of dogmatic religion
morphed into Millie
and extremism it's found the
tehrik-e-taliban Pakistan even non
militant obscurantist spread wide F's
current isms spread wide
it was facilitated by curricular changes
called reforms introduced by General Zia
our history was rewritten in chapters
covering two thousand years of
indigenous Indus history from where
India daro to the arrival of Muhammad
bin Qasim in 711 were excised that space
was filled up with the history of the
Arab world an entire generation was
taught nothing about of the sea Stanny
cochon or gupta ancestors there is no
understanding that our forefathers had
been hindus buddhists and in some cases
also six on the basis of religion alone
we have been denied our heroes even
pre-islamic heroes history textbooks
make no mention of such enlightened
Kings as Kanishka of the Kishan dynasty
or Chander book of the Magnificent
Gupta's history has been rewritten to
excise all evidence of plurality history
has been restated to deprive us of our
heroes it has been revised to take our
history out of Pakistan and to give us
an extraterritorial personality but by
Islam izing our history this has
produced she's a friend
such revisions and arbitrary changes
could more easily be performed by
dictators the religious parties were
thus comfortable with Praetorian ism but
today the progeny of these parties not
only threaten to blow up democracy but
also civil society and the very fabric
of the state itself all this while the
middle class and the lumpin of Pakistan
was suppressed by the general
outmaneuvered by the bureaucrats
brutalized by the police oppressed by
the fuel exploited by the industrialists
and befuddled by the fundamentalist and
was deprived of her voice it needed its
heroes on March 9 2007 the Chief Justice
of Pakistan refused to resign in
submission to the diktat of the army
chief President General Musharraf and
his uniform colleagues that surrounded
him the rare show of defiance triggered
off an immensely popular movement
spearheaded by the lawyers the lawyers
movement in Pakistan sustained over two
years over two years was entirely
nonviolent and peaceful it was an
example of pluralism tolerance and
coexistence in a society ripped about by
chisels and violent contradictions the
black-suited lawyers carried with them
no weapon more lethal than the precepts
of our Constitution and the concepts of
do constitute process and rule of law
they were supported by a vigorous and
vibrant civil society the several
hundred procession throughout Pakistan
every Thursday the several hundred
processions throughout Pakistan every
Thursday epitomized the movement this
pang the complete spectrum of the
population
men women children old and young
students and the lumpin professionals
and high executives farmers and
urbanites poets and writers artists and
sportsmen the nameless and the
celebrities all pitched in together
every Thursday for two years there was a
tear eve square in every city of
Pakistan
this was the Pakistani spring the latest
Pakistani spring but no flags were burnt
we were had no let me just because I was
asked to speak a bit more on this
explain we were we were we were a
positive movement we had no negativity
we were a totally non wound nonviolent
movement we were a totally plural
movement when on the 22nd of March 2000
and the movement had started on the 9th
of March 2007 we decided I met the chief
justice and I said on the 9th of March
2007 the flag on your house was removed
by the police we do not want the police
to raise the flag in your house just
this once we will raise it those who
have struggled for you he said fine and
he said we said we will not come into
your house because we accept the
sanctity of Adi politicize Chief Justice
we will do it from the outside because
the flag poles - flag poles of the
Supreme Court standard and the Pakistan
flag work close to the wall so I
selected there was a large crowd but I
selected 2010 lawyers and 10 people from
civil society who had the lawyers
included two of our senior Hindu leaders
button - pavani and Ram Narayan they
there was they were Christian lawyers
there was one sick lawyer there - six
lawyers in function and incidentally
only both were committed to the movement
there the other flag was the string was
pulled by women students labor
journalists media people who all who had
supported prominent and representatives
of that the movement was truly plural
truly nonviolent in fact Han said I
should recite my verses I can only do
that my poem became the anthem of the of
the movement and in which in which I and
it it resonated with everyone because
among other things I said Mizuki the
Freak nahi or ham sorry a queer
Dounia Barca sorry because Ram Kumari a
Quay and the other it concluded with
muhammad ali jinnah a logo the cottage
asunder Sapna Sokka sorry Taniya para
bogus AIA eight or eight here Ibaka
Horeb such a merabh Sangha our mazhab
hard our Omkara be a Hindu Muslim Sikh
is I harm in some way Karim Carabas this
was where it concluded it was truly pure
plural it was totally normal Island it
was the it was hugely popular the
political parties were driven was sucked
into the movement because the people
came and joined us before the political
parties came in political parties
watched it but then on the fifth of May
2007 the Chief Justice and I I was I was
driving in the Chief Justice sitting
next to me we drove from Islamabad 150
miles along an eight-lane highway to
Lahore for to the Chief Justice and I
had to address the address the Bar
Association in Lahore and there were so
many people stopping us there was so
many people to greet us that the 150
miles every inch every minute was
reported live incidentally so I can't be
lying every inch every minute was
reported life and it took us twenty six
hours to do the journey from Islamabad
to the hall every village on the way
every heart town every house every child
every woman every man was I was around
the car trying to get close to the
vehicle there are photographs of my
vehicle with 23 people on top of the
roof to the SUV etcetera
it was totally utterly nonviolent one
flag was burnt and the American
ambassador called me and
in Multan the American flag is burnt and
you are saying no flags are burnt I went
I addressed the press conference
immediately I said look this is not only
the flag of George Bush and Dick Cheney
and Rumsfeld we are against them this is
the flag of the American people this is
the flag of the Harvard Law School which
has awarded to the chief justice the
third person in the history of the
Harvard Law School - we have been
awarded the Medal of Freedom the first
two people who were awarded the Medal of
Freedom the first two proceeded the
Chief Justice of Pakistan these are good
news from Pakistan this is a good State
Pakistan the good news is that the third
person the first two people who were
awarded this the matter was first was
thought with Justice Thurgood Marshall
for his as a lawyer for his pleading the
case in Brown versus Board of Education
which desegregated black and white
schools in the early 50s and the second
person to have been granted and awarded
the medal was known none less than
Nelson Mandela and the third one is the
Chief Justice sitting president Chief
Justice of Pakistan I said the New York
Bar Association is awarded him honorary
life membership and he is only the
seventh person to maybe have been
granted the new life membership of the
New York Bar Association so we are not
against the Americans we can test the
the position of the American
administration which which comes in my
paper in a wide but we chose Thursday
for all demonstrations Fridays and
natural for Muslims incidentally Friday
the natural Friday the you have a Tahrir
Square every Friday but we chose
Thursday because we wanted to keep it
sort of secular wanted to keep it not
one religion
and every Thursday every town in the
country every town in the country for
two consistent years was its small or
large Tahrir Square every Thursday for
two years there was a Tahrir Square in
every city in Pakistan this was the real
Pakistan that we do not want to hand
over to the intolerant obscurantists the
movement embodied everything that the
future should be peaceful harmonious
plural inclusive nonviolent tolerant and
democratic as the movement brought
millions out onto the streets the
general krypt tottered and turned to
washington to save the hated dictator
the united states then began to stitch
up an arrangement between him and in
mathura benazir bhutto
the late martyred leader of Pakistan
whom he had sworn not to allow back the
movement however forced him
notwithstanding strong us support for
the general first to relinquish the
office of army chief then to allow the
other exiled leader Nawaz Sharif whose
return he and earlier obstructed also to
return and to hold elections despite the
tragic assassination of Benazir Bhutto
despite its louts Ludd claims to the
contrary the United States has been
another consistent opponent of democracy
in Pakistan from the 1950s it has sided
with generals most recently I believe
I'm leaving out instances most recently
the Bush administration having run out
of all options to save the general
supported bare ballot democracy and
continued to stymie efforts to obtain
full constitutional democracy by bare
ballot democracy I mean it is bare
ballot democracy is expressed in the
argument that once elected an
administration has the absolute
discretion to do wrong or right during
its legitimate in your being answerable
only to the electorate at the end of it
there can be no other kind of
intervening accountability the concept
of constant
to tional democracy however puts a rider
on this the electoral mandate has
primacy but is it is only it only gives
one that I one of rival contestants the
authority to govern in accordance with
law and to be judged at all times by an
independent judiciary it couples
franchise with the rule of law with the
tradition of Pakistani military
dictatorships tapering off in two
different versions of democracy harness
to autocratic will the former concept of
birth valid democracy obsesses the
executive more mythically called the
establishment judicial oversight is
resented the bare ballot democracy
argument is fielded every time the court
intervenes to light Iran denied a client
denied a client third world military
dictator by the force of a popular
sentiment the US prefers our the
arbitrariness of bare ballot democracy
over the constraints of constitutional
democracy third-world regimes allied to
it can rule roughshod and arbitrarily in
the former system and yet be called
democratic on the hill this one blind
spot this is one blind spot the
Americans have studiously acquired
leading always to disaster but no strong
stable Parliament can be constructed on
the debris of an independent judicial
evidence edifice it truly independent
and fearless judicially covers the
flanks of electoral Institute electoral
institutions by deterring assaults from
adventurous a waiting in the wings even
today it is the present Supreme Court
that is D legitimize the military gothic
over in the in its sin High Court Bar
Association judgment of 2009 also
recognized at the July 31 judgement it
stands out as a bulwark against
fruitarianism despair it has been now
but rest by the judgment of October 6th
2001 concerning the breakdown of the Law
& Order in Karachi despite such vigorous
civil society movements strong
traditions and vibrant institutions the
West by and large continues to
mischaracterize Pakistan and its people
and here I speak of the Arab springs
because we are Muslims we must be we
must it is assumed be like the Arabs
tolerant of autocracy and the absence of
due process this is the West second
blind spot make no mistake Pakistan is
indeed a Muslim but not an Arab or
Middle Eastern State it is a South Asian
state along with the other people of
South Asia most notably India Bangladesh
and Sri Lanka the Pakistanis share a
deep and indelible aspiration for
democracy and in India independent
judiciary democracy and independent
Jewish justice system remain integral to
the ideal pursued by the people of
Pakistan neither exists in the Arab
world Pakistan cannot do without either
an independent judiciary is integral to
the democratic environment and all this
becomes the more important because
Pakistan is in the theatre of war the
truth is that no war can today be one in
lands that lacked democracy and justice
these lands produce economic and social
inequities if they lack democracy and
justice and and land submerged deep in
economic and social injustice turnout
turnout disaffected elements that in
Pakistan's case are now getting sucked
into the war on terror getting sucked in
favour of terror not justice Pakistan is
the theatre of a war this war must
one but it cannot be won by weapons
alone it can only be won by an empowered
and enlightened populace in the theatres
of war in time only democratic
constitutionalism and an independent
judicial system can lead us to that
ultimate victory one perspective is that
Pakistan has had four military dictators
another is that it is overthrown four
military dictators it has not had one
spring still of uncertain consequence
its people have always strived for a
perpetual spring and faced up to all
challenges in this behalf it has a
unique commitment to full constitutional
democracy and rule of law that is where
the military dictator loses out that is
why the contemporary agents of brutality
and violent religious extremism are
destined to lose a people equipped with
rights and conscious of their value can
never be defeated they always remain as
far as far as pointed out who say a
burning tarif Casa Katia garage jab kisi
Surat Koga Shaheed Garre - soup igneous
or at the La tache latina The Dictator
learns not from history that whenever
night blows out one son Don creates
another one to take its place
that is a citizenry that confident of
itself and its capabilities overreaches
beyond the paranoia of security to
overcome and prevail in all
contestations to democracy that is the
gift of your movement the lawyers
movement has given you that is what you
must cherish and be proud of
thank you it is us what a what a good
note to end the conference on all that
is yes left for me to do is to thank a
number of people yet another samsara
same for the plenary participants who
came from Pakistan from Bangladesh from
New York and all those who have come to
listen I participate in this conference
I also have to thank four groups of
people who have been instrumental
critical fundamental to all of us being
here we've had 18 participants five
panelists and two plenaries and this
could not have happened without the
support and work extensive work done by
a number of people the South Asian
Institute stall woods as they're called
undergraduate students and graduate
students Carlos and Hector undergraduate
students I don't the other that's Carlos
Hector detectors Carlos graduate
students Dolan Lauren Chevalley Shivani
Prasad
the left had meat stall hamsa Hassan
Monta sir Jason and patent graduate
student from Columbia the South Asian
Institute stole words we'd like to thank
all of them
dr. Asura Rosa has been fundamental in
supporting the conference financially
morally emotionally with help helping
with tickets helping with other
arrangements dr. Rosa has been a
benefactor to people who will shy away
and will suddenly go out of the room
when I name them have helped and
probably made this conference not
probably have made this conference and
all the participants have communicated
with them trouble they bullied them and
so forth
bill and Annapoorna as I said they
probably discipline this has been well
and Annapoorna
there she is hiding it so these people
have all helped and made this conference
there's one final vote of thanks that is
to someone who hasn't been thanked who's
been thanking everybody else professor
John aqui Berkeley the director of the
foundation Institute it's this is her
project
she's got all of us involved in this
hassan Abbas Dina myself who helped
think about this but this has been
Johnny Johnny keys conference with our
help and I think we owe a great deal of
thanks for making this possible and
thank you all of you for taking time out
for two days and participating and
making this conference a great success
thank you very much
you